heute ist luca meine damen und herren
jetzt vielleicht hinter eingeblendet wir
machen heute eine super pizza zwei
challenger wir essen nämlich di luca
pizza 2 ohne handy doch keiner sehen
deswegen habe ich natürlich eine
wunderbare und zwei vorbereitet meine
damen und herren in der max netter weise
besorgt hat im revier nebenan finanziert
bei mir
wir berufen dass ich schon auch 250
jahre vorbereitet hat die pizza kommt
barbara direktor prof
zu acht minuten rein wir warten dass sie
fertig ist
die zeit ist abgelaufen die pizza ist
das heißt wir holen die erstmals
offenbarte sich so wenn die pizza
überhaupt geschnitten meine damen hockey
clubs jeder hat von uns zweien wird nun
zwei stücke bekommen und dann den westen
wachsen und ich gegeneinander ich auch
zeit aber werden gegeneinander war sie
die hitze ohne ende hast du die scheiße
freunde jeder zwei stücke auf seinem
teller
die pid sei hausgemacht gibt es
natürlich immer die medica deutsche
brighton wo werdet ihr wird ein name ist
sogar nur hass luca wieder so eine kraft
hat die macht die direkt aus japan so
viel hunger ja zum medium um bei mir
auch wenn ich habe auch nicht so richtig
hunger aber dann haben wir wenigstens
gleichen voraussetzen auf die plätze
fertig los
[Musik]
und schmeckt eigentlich nie wieder
schnell nach vorne und fragt die dame
kommen und sagen gut wir können ja auch
in dem lägen momentan ist noch ziemlich
gleich daneben bezogen
[Applaus]
wir warten die schlimm das anzusehen
werden wird das video könnt ihr auch
immer mehr videos ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen alter
[Musik]
hey ohne händler
[Applaus]
die wirkung wird vorrangig wie krankhaft
wenn der midcom kraft auf einen
positiven trend ab
heute ja sagen noch gar nicht fertig
[Musik]
irgendwie kannst du dir vor das maxxi
gazetten absolut entspannt am reden im
interagieren der neuen struktur oder die
oder wieso willst du dir die stücke
tritt zurzeit läuft das traurige ich
glaube ich hatte war gegen dich verloren
wenn ich mit händen gegessen hatte ich
bin ich so langsam letztes jahr machen
nicht genau das gleiche bei meiner
ersten luca blitzer gemacht wohin gehst
du dabei
und da hat auch max bruch ich dachte ich
hätte nicht verbessert aber deswegen
schallte es immer noch ein langsamer
esser einfach weiter auf meine erste
vielleicht was wir noch so
desorganisiert nach visualisiert noch
nicht euphorisch
und wie sieht es richtig toll man es
selber nachdenken kommen dann fragen
wollte versorgen
[Musik]
danke dafür wird auf jeden fall hier vom
video meine damen und herren ich hasse
die weiße flagge sachen das so wenn euch
das video gefallen das gerne mal einen
like das könnte eventuell sonst auch das
bekenntnis jetzt mit der pizza machen
vielleicht mit einem anderen youtuber
beispielsweise ich würde sagen dass wir
hier aber auf dem blog kannst du dich
bei mir entschuldigen dialog max kann
ebenfalls ein video zu meiner tür raus
gehauen und in dem video haben wir die
pizza gegessen in kleinen stücken
vertreten weil er die gesamten tisch und
wir mussten sie blind suchen wenn ihr
sehen wollt schon online linken
beschneiden
[Musik]